Because we're live.
If it sounds good.
Well, good morning.
Good morning.  Good morning.
Good morning.
Well, yes, it sounds perfect.
Let's see, let's see, let's see, let's see what we
find today
connecting some users.
Let's see if I can also stream on
Discord.
We'll put Discord here.   They can
barely hear anything here.
Okay, I think we're
ready here with Discord too.   We'll be
broadcasting
via Boomap.   Uh-huh
.  Ready.  So, we have... Good
morning everyone.  Let's begin this
session by providing market context and
explaining
some things we're seeing, as well as
some
Orderflow indicators.
So, this is going to be an
extremely good session, one
that we're going to incorporate.  Ready?
Okay, let's see, let's see, let's see.  Come on,
we're starting
here.
Let's take a moment to see
how things are going on Discord.  Okay.  Ready.
Well, for those on Discord I'll be
streaming a
different screen, since on Discord
I can only stream one screen,
but on YouTube...  Remember that they have a
link on YouTube so you can
also go and watch it,
where it looks much, much better.  Ready.
I'm here on Bootmap.
We already have a shift in what
is the
zero range here, right?
The different levels.  Remember that
the line is
the open interest.  This little red one is
also open interest.
Uh,
the green lines we found here are
from Classic, Classic volume.  This
red line down here from the Classic, I
also show it here on
YouTube.  There it is.  Let's
see if we can put it on top.  There it
is.  Perfect.  Here I am again
explaining it here on YouTube.
Well, then we
're relatively bullish.  Well,
I'm working, I'm here working
on another computer.  Ready?
Therefore, you will see that we will be
a little more fluid in what
we were doing yesterday.
Okay,
so you also have this in mind, we're going to be
a little more fluid in
this session.
Uh, let's
go to
Exactly.  Let's go here for what's
on the web.  Ready.  Let's go to state.  We're also going to
open up what is order flow.   Uh-huh
.  If we see that it's working
quite fast,
uh, when is the computer change?
Okay,
let's see it as we have it.  Let's remove
this for a moment.
Let's put here what the net is, the
net gets.  Let's do a
quick summary of what we've seen so far in the
market.  It's been approximately 7 minutes
since opening.
Once again we have everything that is
bullish gets.  All these days we have
been totally bullish on the net
gets
e
while we are going to see the orders.
We are in the delta.
There we see the delta.  Ah, but here I have to
change, excuse me.  Change
instrument.  I'm standing on, let's
put CPX correlated with it.
Remember that we have different
stickers that are related, they are
practically multiplied,
right?  We're already there.  Perfect.  And
perfect.  Or well, here we see it
differently.  We're starting with the
guest.  Well, at this moment we are
starting bullish with the get
above 250,
we also have the get below which is
the net
1 of t, right?  Just a moment,
please.
There we are.  What a shame about this place.  Okay, so
, what are we talking about?  Okay, today
we're going to explain
some indicators,
uh, some Order Flow metrics.
Ready.  Let's focus on the
aggregate metric, which I've been asked about quite a few times
.  Several people have written to me asking me to
explain a little bit about the
order flow metrics of our
Orderflow package.
Remember that we have
different packages available.  We're going to
work on the order flow package.
Remember that we also have a 50%
discount for the first month, which you
can try out on the platform.
Okay, let's open up what is the
aggregate.  Here it is.
Let's just leave what is the
agricate eh of the certo.
So that we don't get too
confused.  Ready.
Let's put it right here.  What are
we going to find here?  Let's
find a middle ground, a point,
here it is, a middle ground, right?  Which
would be
Siam, right?  The Siam line the
Siam line.  We have what is the aggregate
of the put, right?  It's the aggregate
of the
red putí and the aggregate of the call,
green line, right?  What are we going to find
in this aggregate?
different delta impulses
and that's why it tells you here that it is the
aggregate of the remember it is a calculation
of the delta.
Therefore, any
incoming volume aggregation can be
visualized here more
graphically and compared
to a truly exponential movement
in price.  We'll go and see it.
Ready.  We're also going to do a
historical survey so we can see and
visualize it.  Let's say, what happened
in the delta?  And we're also going to look at what
the state is, but the orders are
completely separate from strike to
strike.  Remember that we have the
different filters,
right?, from the profile option, which are
delta, gamma, bama, char, right?  And
we'll stop pressing one of
these, right?  We're going to see that
type of graph, right?  Which is
completely independent
of all
call sales and purchases.   We'll
see him explain.  Okay, we'll
explain it.  Let's see.  Ah, well,
while we're explaining, we're also
learning a little bit about how
the market is being managed,
because they're also interested in
visualizing what the market is like, in addition to the explanation.
Let's leave it at that for now.  Let's leave it at that for now
.  We are located
here.  We're going to let it run its course, but we
'll explain it if something happens.
Ready.  When an event happens, we're going to
explain
what happened,
right?
And we're going to buy it, let's say,
with the previous days.  Let's see
if we can find something similar.
Ready.
Uh, I'm going to open it, just a moment.
that open this way.
Oh, I hope I haven't cut the "
Wait until I connect another computer" and I do
n't want to.  Ah, yes, I cut it.   I
cut it, I cut it, I cut it.  Too bad.
I've cut the live stream of "
A ver" here.   I'm
sorry about you.  I cut the
live stream of what Bootmap is on Discord.
Hey, when you can, you can show the
zero line comparison in the Bobmap.
Uh, well, they also asked me about
the line zero of the Bootmap.  This
indicator is in test mode
for bootmap.
The zero line is being developed,
since more things will be integrated
into the history of the different
indicators.  So, we're going to start
having a history of the delta.  My idea is
that we have a history of the Delta, a
history of the Gamma, and a history of the
Classic,
too.  Oh no, even here we have
the history classit.  This is the history
of Classic that we see here.
Hey, the green line is here.  Here is the
green line.  I believe it was also situated
at this point.  This is the history.  This
is the history of what the
Classic is in open interest.  Ready?
So, we're going to have that update
soon, uh, not right now,
but we will have it soon.
Uh, in what we saw yesterday, we had
taken a long position because I think it
turned out positive directly on
the zero range.  Remember that you can take
positions on the break of the zero
range if the break is relatively
large or if it is going to be the
continuation of the upward trend.  By putting less here, I
can place an operation and I can
continue the transaction, knowing
that there are still orders to
consume, right?
Ah, I'm going to the side.
Well, I think we still don't
see
anything in
what is the aggregate.
Well, I'll explain this
here too.  Then
I want to see what it is.
Here we are.  Here.  So, as
we visualized yesterday, remember
that our zero-range line is a
midpoint, right?  This allows
us to visualize, in a
partial way, whether we are going to build a
bearish trend or an
upward trend.
Uh, regarding that calculation.
Notice that as an indicator, right?  At the
beginning of the market, while it's being
reorganized, right?  As it opens up
,
notice how our zero-gamut
is functioning as support, right?
That's definitely a point in their favor.  A
break below indicates, well,
a short bearish trend,
depending on the
different indicators we
look at.
Okay,
let's believe
Okay, we're here in G. We're already
here.  So, what did we find?
Let's duplicate that tab.  The
good thing is that here on this computer
I can duplicate as many tabs as I can
because it doesn't stick directly.
What are we going to see?  We'll see
that we have a balanced chart today,
right?  We have a balanced chart,
right?  As on other days, we found
a bit of an imbalance
on the side of purchases in the
different
filters.  the different filters.
I'm going to open the chat here too
so I can read your messages.
Yes, perfect.
Uh, the different filters that we
apply, right?, from 0 to
1. Notice that at this moment
we find that there is a
small balance within the market.   There has
n't been an explosion yet, let's say,
bullish or bearish.
And let's move on now to what the delta is.
We found the same thing.  We have a
positive delta support point at
78830.
Over here we have a delta of
6795.
Remember that this can change as
we move forward
directly
through the market.   There's
little documentation here.
Here it is.
Uh,
what else?  What else do we have here?
Let's also look at what the range is.
Uh, we have the relatively
negative range, right?  This negative range
gives us a small bearish push
for the moment, right?  It has to be
balanced, let's say, with the
positive range.  We have a negative gamma at
68825,
which I think we can visualize
in Boomap.  Let's go here, to Boom,
so we can see it too, you can
visualize it.  Remember that our
tool here in the
integration with Bomma we can also see
the level relatively at 6825.
Let's mark it, let's put this line
here.  6825. There it is.  TRUE?  That would be
like our first, let's say,
foothold.  Notice that he keeps changing.
He has a yellow outline.  It has
a yellow outline that allows us to see that
this would be the peak.  Ready?   Let's
see, looking over here, we have
a negative delta way down here,
right?  Let's say, it's not
correlated.  Remember that correlation is much
better.  When both are
located at the same price
within the spot, notice how our
price has already been indicated below the zero
range.  This gives it a small, let's say,
downward momentum.
Let's see what happened.
Vamosica, it's a shame there's so much
screen swapping, but I think it's
much
better this way.
Look, now we're going to see the
example here.  Do you remember that I told you we were going to
look at the example about 5
minutes ago?  10 minutes, five.  10
minutes.  Exactly.  Uh, we see that there is
a drop in the aggregate.  This
little drop, the aggregate, right?  It is
a put event.  Look how it falls,
right?  There we see that there is a drop.
What can you see?  Well, to
have a small
average, right?  an average of
how many points it is falling, let's say, in
volume
by volume, referring to
these values ​​on the left side of
the screen that we can all
visualize.   It
goes from line zero, right?  These are
all the metrics.  Remember that all
metrics have a dotted line
within the graph, and above is
positive and below is negative.
We have a maximum that reached 200,
around 241 here.
We also have a minimum here that
is around 675.
That leads me to believe
that
the aggregation at this moment has just
surpassed the point of going below zero.
Let's take a look at this little movement, shall we
?  At what point did a strike
happen,
right?  It's relatively small, but
let's see if we can find it.
Ready.
Let's get started.  Remember that we have the
schedule, we have the schedule
below.  If you look, we have the
schedule right below and it tells us that it's at
9:50.
Okay.  Let's go at 9:50.  Let's go over here
,
sorry, let's go over here.  TRUE?
We can take 950 this way
.  And let's see, we're going to point them out,
although it's relatively small, so we won't be able
to see it, but
the idea is that you can see it.  950 con02.   Let's see
if we can play it
.   Let's
see if the increase can be observed.
Okay.  It's not relatively.
Ah, no, I found it here.  Yes, I
think I've found it here.
No, I didn't find it.  [laughs]
Wait a moment.  Let's see if we can
visualize it.
I'm going to make it a little bit bigger.   Let's
see if we can find it visually here.   He's going to
pause it and put them on one by
one.
If the movement is relatively small
, I do
n't think we'll be able to visualize the expansion.
Ah, okay.  Here it is.  Here it is.   Did you
see it?   I'm
going to center it.  I'm going to elaborate
a little.  Look at our... Well,
here I have to explain directly
how this type of graph works.
This small
chart
is relatively important if we want to
see what is happening internally
at each price level.
On the left side, if you draw
an imaginary line, right?  We have
the lines.  Uh, let's see if we
can
change their color, but we will
explain.  Okay, on the right side,
on the right side we have the calls,
right?, orange ones.
Let's go here.
These are the calls.  If you press,
if you press, no, or if you
place the mouse, you will find volume
call, volume call, volume call, which
are the
orange bar lines on the
right side, right?
These are cabbage purchases, ready?  so
that they take it into account.  A purchase of
calls and
the purple one is a purchase of puts,
right?  Otherwise, we have a
cabbage purchase, right?  A purchase of a
colcista (a type of stock) is considered bullish,
right?
Uh, and the opposite case, that is, the other
left side, we have a short, a
what?  A short call, well, a
call sale, sorry, a bearish call sale,
right?
Which is basically being a bass player.  Okay, and here
we also have the buyer's put option,
right?
And on the opposite side we have the
seller's put.
What's going on with these levels?  Okay, here we
go a little bit into visualizing how
order pushing is very similar to
the Bookmap order book.
Because?
Um, when you place a limit order,
notice that when you place a
limit order, when you see a
limited liquidity order, it can push
the price up or pull it down,
right?  In other words, it functions as part
of the liquidity, which can push the
price from one side to the other or
attract it.
Therefore, these points act as a
price attraction, right?  These
points act as a
price attraction, as liquidity.  It's, let's say, like
the same terminology when it comes to
comparing it to the Boomman.
Well, graphically it's quite
convenient, and it allows us to
identify
what happened within the
aggregate.  So, the aggregate tells you,
uh, look, a small volume of change
on the side of a put or a call,
right?  It can be bearish or it can be
bullish.
like the one we see right
here.  This was set at 50.03.
950.03.
Here it is 950 with 03.
Let's see.  That must have been
a put, right?
If we can see it here,
let's back up.   Go ahead
a little bit.  There it is.  Look, did you
see it?  There it is.  volume put.  That's why
the aggregate
indicates that it's a put aggregate,
right?  And an aggregate of put, what?  A
bearish put aggregate.   Did you
understand me?  Ready.  It clearly
tells me he's a bear because he pulled
down.  Okay.  And if we look here,
here at this, add it, we see it
here, there you'll see it, man.
He's a bass player, right?
What price range are we aiming for?  At 68.35.
68.35
at 50.03.
You'll see that they
took this [ __ ] away from me, right?  They
took this bullish put out of my pocket, right?  And they
added it to the book a little further
up.
That could work in my favor, giving me
room for the price to continue
falling, right?  And I bet
the price will continue the downward trend.   In
other words, that small aggregate
tells me that
two options can occur.  I'll
explain it here.  Two options can occur
.
Remove an aggregate, remove a
put, right?  Or a call, right?  And
add one for me immediately,
right?  that we will be able to
visualize in the aggregate of the order
flow.  Or they might also
add me
without needing to remove any part of the "
del" of a call or a put.
Ready?
It's exactly the same.  The
same can be said for those
who have studied bootmap.
It's exactly the same.  We're going to put the
bootmap here.  Momentico.
It's exactly the same when I'm
adding a limit order to push the
price up or when I'm removing the
order to let the price continue,
right?  In this example case, we will
visualize it here.  Look,
let's put it here.  Look, when I
add a limit order here, right?
When I add it, right?
Limited order quantity?  Ah, 137.
A limit order of 137 drives the
price up because it's a buy limit order
, right?  There he is telling me,
look, it's an order of 137 compared to
the book.  Remember that you can
visually
compare books.  If you look closely, this
is Boommap's order book.  And he
tells me, ah, look, you guys are more or
less getting a visual average, it's not
going over 107, 77 here 80 89
uh, here 140
3, look, it marks that it's a
maximum point, right?  It's an aggregate.  It's
exactly the same, it's the same
terminology,
right?  So, we can
combine both tools to
tell him, "Oh, look, they're doing
a put aggregation and
a bearish limit order aggregation
,
uh, a bearish limit order to create
a continuation, right?"
That can boost the
price,
uh, like in this case that we saw, uh,
that we saw in our
Acábot.
It's super important that you also look into
this.  Ah,
here we found the aggregate.  Let's see, yes,
look, see.  Did you see it again?  I
want you to visualize
these types of movements very clearly.  When
you see this, it's an addition that
we can consider.  Remember
that our state package is presented
in a way that's a little more
visual,
yes, but with the exact price.  With the
exact price and location, right?
In comparison, let's say, with
this order flow, we see that the aggregate,
right?  It settled right here,
although the price we're seeing continued
to be slightly bullish.  Let's see how far it
went.  It reached 68.31.
The order came
at 68.35.
One can refer to it completely as
if it were a resistor, right?  I
mean, I can place, let's say,
well, this is also another
super important point.
You will find that the aggregates
can be close to the price or they can
be far from the price.   Well, let's say we do
n't know for sure exactly when we can
get to the point where we can apply
exponential motion,
but it's very similar to how Boa works,
an aggregation of one order in terms
of volume, right?  If I add a
volume close to the price, it tends to
influence it because I'm adding liquidity and
unbalancing the book.  It
works exactly the same way here in the
options.  I create an imbalance in
the book.  And how do I unbalance
the book?  Well, by adding one or two
orders to an option, right?
Uh, obviously for the purpose
of tracking, well, so that they can
see it visually in each of
their tools.
Ready?
Not only will we be able to
visualize what a
single-strike aggregate is, but we will also be
able to visualize
continuous ones.  What are continua?
Okay, let's see, let's see what continuous things are.  That's why
I'd like to show you an
example, so to speak.  Let's go to
mm
which are continuous.  Well, they
are continuous and for me they are also
relatively important to a
bearish or bullish impulse, right?  Depending on
where it's located,
but let's say in this case we're going to
zoom in a little bit here so we can see
the profile a little bigger so you can see it
here the aggregate changes
sides, right?  There.
And what is continuous?
That at the moment I
remove this
volume of put, right?  This
bullish put volume that you were indicating, ah, look, we
were working this bullish put volume
at 68.30, right?  And
we immediately add a
bearish put volume, right?
Otherwise, right?
But
simultaneously, we will be able to see,
relatively occasionally, that
two volumes are added at different levels.
That won't be indicated by the aggregate.  In other words
, the aggregate won't show us this
.  We can see in the aggregate that it
was totally bearish, right?  But he's not
going to tell you how many were bearish, he's not
going to say, "Oh, look, a strike was added at
such and such a price, I don't know, with 200
volume, and another strike at such and such a price with
5000 volume, right?" Instead, he's
going to tell you, "A volume was added,
right? You consider that
bearish volume at this moment and we
expect the move to be
bearish, right?" But it's extremely
important when they're simultaneous. What
happens when they're simultaneous? Well, the
aggregation of a simultaneous bearish put
can give me a much
bigger impulse. What do I mean by much bigger?
In this case,
if this aggregate, right, that was
located here, had
not only appeared here at
68.35,
but if another one had been added here at
68.45,
we have two aggregate volumes of
bearish puts coming in,
and that can give me  A
power that continues to be bearish,
right? And they can
clearly act as support or resistance,
right? Remember that this doesn't
only happen with puts,
but also with
bullish calls or a put or a buy put as
well. Did you understand? Any questions?
I hope it wasn't a
little tedious and I hope
everyone in
this session understood. I know it's a little difficult to
visualize, but in
reference to any type of trading
you do, right? It's good to
consider because it
allows you to see where
the participants with the biggest hands are entering
, right? You could say the
strongest hands.
Uh,
let's see, let's see, let's see. Okay. Uh,
well, we see that we made a
bullish addition.
There we see. Well, look at what I was
telling you. Let's see, over here we have,
let's see what happened here.
Well, we have here that our
zero range was working  As
support, right? It breaks through and
positions itself as
resistance. Notice how it positions itself
as resistance.
Again, this resistance, this zero
range, propels us again with
the breakout. This happens every
day. Like I told you
yesterday, this happens practically every
day. It's good, let's say, for us to
take positions with the zero range. It's
simple enough that you can analyze it
daily and
not complicate things with all the
tools that Gesbot offers.
Everyone has their own way of managing
their trading style, right?
Since we're all different.
I'm explaining this to you, but
you might apply it
differently, and the idea is to use it as
a reference for your trading.
The breakout of the zero range gives me
all this bullish momentum, right? Let's
see, over
here we have this small
positive range that we see was referenced with
a limit order. It can also be
referenced as a bullish entry point.  This
movement reflects
all the movement that has
occurred, right?
I can, let's say, take an order here,
a buy order, right? Let's
see, they're written, yes? I can take a
buy order. Why? Because I have
references. Let's say that's
all context, what I'm
seeing, it's not for you to
directly place an order, I'm
explaining, I'm entering directly,
but it's what one is seeing, what
we're analyzing
in part, but there are, let's say,
many points missing to analyze, let's say,
those types of entries. We have the zero range.
I can, let's say, place my stop
below, I can support this zero range,
I can assume that there is
liquidity above, although I still see liquidity
below, as if to defend,
let's say, directly the zone. We have
all the upward momentum, we are seeing
bullish increases above the zero
range. We would have to use other
types of tools, let's say, I don't know, in
Order Flow,
in order, in Delta, to  Let's see if our
position is, let's say,
completely valid. But these
trading points are exactly very good
for taking steps within
our trade. We needed to know
exactly what happened here in this step,
in this downward step, because it may have already
been a small
upward movement and a continuation is coming,
but let's see how it could affect
our trade,
right? Look,
notice that at this
moment it reaches our
line again, our zero line. It can
take hold there again as part of the
support, right?
Remember that our zero line is our
reference point. That's why I put
this precisely below the
zero line, right? Below this level of the
range, because the zero line tells you, "Ah,
look, this is relatively ours, I don't know
if you've seen what
the Bwap is."  It is very similar,
practically very similar to what
the BWAT is.  Uh, they can even combine
both tools, what is BW and
what is zero gamut, right?  which
is like a weighted midpoint of volume,
you could say, right?  Uh,
but when you guys take an entry
within BW, you obviously
reference it with another type of
analysis, right?
Okay, let's
move on here, let's move on to what's here
again.
We're going to change.
Okay, let's see if there was any other
movement inside.
Ah, here it's more perfect.  Look at
this, look at this.
So, what is
this little [ __ ] referring to then?  This little
put is telling me, "Ah, look, it's a
bullish put, right? It's a bullish one that
was added within the book, and we're
placing it right here at this little
point, right? What I was telling you is,
we have to look at the other
tools to see what's
happening. Here we also have a small
bearish volume,
right? We're also referencing it here.
Ah, let's see, yes, we're also referencing it
here. Here again we also have
another bullish put, but relatively
small as well. I think the largest one was
this one here. Let's
visualize it now on
our state chart.
Okay.
Let's look at our state chart.
These are right at 13.
13. Ah, well, this one too. Let's see, you're
also going to notice
these aggregates are very similar
in volume
on certain
timeframes. I think I'll
explain that another day, but you will
find the timeframes very
, very similar. We have  It
's 10:3 here, it's
10:13. Let's look for it,
uh, although you know what, let's look for it
in the, in the, in the delta. Yes, let's look for the
delta. I like the delta better, that one,
yeah, that's a little bit, like knowing
where it went, but what
the delta does is make that little
negative and positive distribution,
right?
Uh,
that negative and positive distribution,
but I really like it a little bit
more. And let's, I think we've got it loaded
now. Let's look for it, let's
see it soon. I do
n't see it. It
must be this one.
Like the Acab, if it appears.
If it appears, even better. Let's
see,
uh, give me a moment, please.
I'm going to get a little bit of water.
What a shame, I almost drowned here. Uh
, well, wait a moment.
Let's go back to our,
to our boom.
Uh, look at our line, our
zero line, well, uh, look, if
we had placed the stop below
the point  Zero, because it would have
triggered our stop loss, right? Um, you can
directly take an entry point,
since we'd have to see, let's say, what
happened here at this point.
I was telling you, always try to
combine it with other types of
tools. Perhaps in order flow,
this small point here could have been
a really exponential delta
directly in futures that gave me
this small upward impulse,
right? Up to here, right? Um, it picks up
to this point where the pulse occurred,
where the upward point occurred. This
10 o'clock, I think it could have been some kind
of news, if I'm not mistaken. Um, and the
continuity, notice that in the
continuity, right there it refers
to the impulse. Let's
see, just a moment.
Okay, continuing here, uh, and let's
see what happened with that
aggregation. Okay, let's look for it
here. If we find it
here, we have to find it. That
small aggregation. I
think we could be there.
I'll play the audio while they
talk here.  In the background. Ah.
Well, here we are again, sorry to be
back here. Um, we have the
aggregation here, right? Well, because here
's the audio. Uh, this
put aggregation was bullish, as you could
see.
Look, of the 103 with 17. Did you see it here?
Here it is. It
would be this one with approximately -89,
but way, way below. It's way, way
below. I do
n't see another one here.
Here they made another small aggregation,
right?
But bearish. Immediately, when
we
see this aggregation, right? This
aggregation, let's see
if we can see it. This is a
radiation of -89 in volume, right? I'm not
going to talk about millions, I'm not going to
talk about trillions, just 89 so as
not to confuse you, right? Which are
the values ​​we are
visualizing here within our
chart.
Uh, immediately,
a second later,
a small aggregation on the
bearish side. We go from...
to 373,
right?
But they're working it
just below,
and they're also adding a little bit of
volume here, if I'm not mistaken. Uh-huh. Yes,
down there,
right? So, notice that at those
points, they're adding a
bullish put here, and immediately
a second later they return it,
but they maintain it up to here. Uh, it
's good, let's say, for us to see it here
directly, in what I think is... I
don't see it anymore.
This must have been... I
don't see it.
Ah, it's not this one.
This is... Uh-huh
. This has to be at three o'clock, and
of course, here they are. Here you can see it
perfectly.
The tricky part
is finding the exact point. I
have to zoom in quite a bit on the
chart. What we're going to do is
find the exact point, right?
We're going to locate ourselves here on the aggregate.
And look, it places you here. Look, it's from
3:18
to 3:19. Is
it...  Remember when I told you that
simultaneous orders could be added? Right?
When simultaneous orders are added, it's,
let's say, more relative
to a certain movement.
Notice that what we're doing is
adding them.
The
simultaneous orders were added. I lost track of it. Here it is. If they
are simultaneous orders above
the price. You saw it. Here they are.
Okay, here are
this put
and this put. Let's visualize it so you can see it
. There it is. This is the
example I wanted to show you,
this simultaneous order aggregation we were talking about.
If you've left any comments,
no, everything's fine here. If you have any
questions, don't hesitate. Uh, for those on
Discord, remember that I'm
explaining,
I have a Discord stream here to
Bootmap, this
would be it.
Let's zoom in a little more on the chart
so you can see it.
There it is. Right?
And over here, on YouTube, I have the
stream
on our platform.
It's our platform directly on  The
website. Let's see that it's much more detailed
than what actually happened at that
point.
Look at this small aggregation. This
aggregation,
this double volume aggregation, although it
may be bullish, right? It's an
aggregation, let's say, like the
order book, I mean, it's kind of
stopping me, it stops the price, I mean, it
stops it and tells me, "Look, you're
not going past here, you're not going to go past, although
relatively above it, right?"  There were
queamos we are in
son -23
and around here -214.
Adding it all up, it's a
pretty relative volume, huh?
We also see the volume starting from
300 here. This was the 300, what?
Here are 302
through 599.
Here it is.  Did you see it?  The 302,599.
So this small
volume aggregation, right?  He tells me, "Look,
there are two ways we can
interpret it.
A pause, a pause in an
exponential movement within the market, because let
's say the price is, I mean, the
price is going up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up
, up, and it tells you, look,
pin, make a pause, I just added a
relatively large volume that
allows me to pause. It seems like a
small pause to me, and that's why this small
point can act as
resistance. Notice,
it acts as resistance. Did you
see that? That's why we saw that
small shift.
Understood so far?
Hm.
I think I
'll leave
the explanation of how to
interpret it,
how to interpret this volume above
the price and how to interpret it
below the price, for tomorrow. Also, how to
interpret it... because it's already
10:30. Tell me a little more
about the topic, but yes, we're going to
explain it, we're going to explain it in the
following videos, how to interpret it
when it's added..."  Precisely
close to the price, right? How they're
added remotely. Here we
have it completely remotely.
Exactly. Yes, sir. Let's see it.
Ah, well, let's see it in the delta.
Let's see the Delta.
Tir, tir,
ton.
Here it is. If it's this.
No,
tan, tan, tan, tan, tanan. Let's
load the history. Remember that we can
load the history when we refresh the
tab
here. On YouTube, it's a
positive pause. Sir, sir,
that's correct,
huh? Still. Come out here, here,
here. P. There they are, there they are. Boom.
Uh, how do you know? How do you know?
Uh, here on YouTube, it's a
high positive pause. Yes, sir.
Very good.
There it is. There it is. Okay. Aggregation of
positive volumes, right? You
can visualize it.
Uh, clearly I wanted to do them here
because this is
doing the split. It's doing the
order split.
Uh,
there it is.  Uh, then that
little pause tells me, "Well, look, we do
n't want, like, you to go
too far from
there."
Well, there are two things here.
Remember that this adds up for me.
This delta thing, well, it's
relatively like the weighted sum,
let's say, of all the strides, right?
Uh,
the nu puntu goes precisely
if the study is located precisely, let's say, in this
whole part of this whole volume.
Here we can visualize it a little more
graphically, but here directly in the
delta it is much more graphic, much more
graphic.
Ready.  Please keep that in mind.
Look, at that moment for us, that
can be attraction; obviously, it's the
little pause, right?
But it can also attract me, it
can also work for me like an imam.
Well,
well, looking at the bootmap we
have
here, I'm going to get the news, let's
say.  I can make my
point here, where is it?  I don't know about this, I'd
say get it to break
even, right?
Break after this
move.  It's a shame I
'm not showing you the bootmap here.  There it is.
What could we have found?  Well,
our Coglama worked as a
support.
We saw that it fluctuates a bit, returning
again to our range zone, right?
reacting
the next time and we're
almost catching up.  We have a
small resistance here in the
delta section, right?  We have a negative delta here
.  Let's assume that we're going to
take, let's say, our profit at
that point because it's already a negative delta.
That might influence me to make
a small bearish move,
huh?  And
what else?  What else?  What else?  What else?
What else?  What else?  So
, what are they doing there?
Questions, questions for now.  If you
have any questions, feel free to
write to me here.
Uh,
you saw that uh, it already took, let's say, as
our target.  Remember that it is
entirely theoretical;
this entry is not meant to be taken.
Investment advice is included
in our description of
our shipment.  Uh, this little pause
that we saw here, right?, a
price hold due to
this negative delta, right?
major negative delta.  Um,
what I was telling you yesterday is
that if we're referring to a
downward trend, then let's try to find
positions in negative delta.  If we are
in an upward trend, let's try to
find positions at a positive delta to continue
the trend.  There we saw that there was
precisely the breaking of this
positive delta and so let's say it can continue
directly to look for higher points.
Notice how the deltap has shifted
upwards, it's swapped
upwards, did you see it?  and
it is directly correlating with
this negative gamma.
This correlation between the two, this
correlation between the two, is much
greater than the price, let's say, tends to
flow and arrive as a point of
attraction of the price or point of
resistance.
Understood?
Uh, I did
n't understand, they wrote to me here on
YouTube.  The fact that the small company moved
north
also raises the price.
A little more explanation.
Implied volatility.  Let's look at the beacon
over here.   I'll have to
explain that in
the next videos, but let's
make a short clip of this live stream.  Ready?
Well, I'll say goodbye here.
I hope you really enjoyed today's
analysis
of what aggregate is, right?
We can visualize what the
aggregate is.  It's a very, very good indicator,
in terms of taking a reference point towards
liquidity.  Right
, don't worry.
And also, let's talk about how to identify
the movements that will pause the
price.
Tomorrow we might see what
implicit oratily is.
Ready.  I would like us to see that, I
mean,
this, these little dots, we are going to visualize all these
dots
.
all these little dots.   We
are going to explain this
implicit profile, which is also relatively
important.  Everything is important.  The
point is that you should look for
the best, look for what's best for
your operations.
Ready.
All these movements that
you see here in the delta of
this entire aggregation,
right?  Notice how it moves,
how they remove liquidity, how they remove, how they
add, add, add and add, add and
add.  All of this is so that they can
start studying it
because they will be able to
see how it behaves, see where
the market is headed.
Can we test the indicator for Boom?
No, he hasn't seen the available version yet
.  There is a version that can be
found on our Discord channel.   You'll
find it there in the
bootmap section under integrations.   You
can scroll through it and you'll
find that version.  Uh,
let's see if we're also in the mood
to talk to Bootmap about doing this
integration.  Remember that there is no
other indicator that shows us the
profile and shows it to us
in this way, so beautifully, so
beautifully, when we
see these charts, right?  From seeing
these reaction zones.   Right now
we're working on getting it
marked, I'd like us to stop, uh,
here I am, here I am showing the
boomar.  Ah.  Ah.  Well, I didn't show them the other one
.  Too bad.  Here we are seeing what it
is...
What would we like to put?  I would like to at
least include the history.
The history of the delta.
I think the
history of the delta is extremely important.  Because?
Because if you look closely, this delta keeps
changing, right?  It keeps changing from side
to side.  It moves from positive delta to
negative delta.  And I'd
like to see that story on Boom.
Uh, exactly like it was
the zero range.  The Cer Gama includes the
History and the Cero Gama, right?  Which
tells me the areas where
the zero range is moving.  And that is extremely
important.
Hey, 10:40, say hi to them here.  My
name is Juan.  Remember that my name
is Juan.  You can find me here
on Discord and write to me with
any questions or comments about
these videos.  If you liked it, don't
forget to like the video here for
many more videos.  Uh, they would
directly support our channel and a
subscription as well.  Thanks a lot.   See you
tomorrow.